this episode is brought to you by
element spelled lmnt
what on earth is element it is a
delicious sugar-free
electrolyte drink mix i've stocked up on
boxes and boxes of this it was one of
the first things that i bought
when i saw covid coming down the pike
and i usually use one to two per day
element is formulated to help anyone
with their electrolyte needs and
perfectly suited to folks following a
keto low carb or paleo diet or if you
drink a ton of water and you might not
have the right balance that's often when
i drink it or if you're doing any type
of endurance exercise
mountain biking etc another application
if you've ever struggled to feel good
on keto low carb or paleo it's most
likely because even if you're
consciously consuming electrolytes
you're just not getting enough and it
relates to a bunch of stuff like a
hormone called aldosterone blah blah
blah when insulin is low but suffice to
say
this is where element again spelled lmnt
can help my favorite flavor by far is
citrus salt
which is a side note you can also use to
make a kick-ass
no sugar margarita but for special
occasions obviously
you're probably already familiar with
one of the names behind it
rob wolff r-o-b-b rob wolf who is a
former research biochemist
and two-time new york times best-selling
author of the paleo solution and wired
to eat
rob created element by scratching his
own itch
that's how it got started his brazilian
jiu jitsu coaches turned him onto
electrolytes
as a performance enhancer things clicked
and bam
company was born so if you're on a low
carb diet or
fasting electrolytes play a key role in
relieving hunger cramps headaches
tiredness
and dizziness sugar artificial
ingredients coloring
all that's garbage unneeded there's none
of that in element
and a lot of names you might recognize
are already using element it was
recommended to be
by one of my favorite athlete friends
three navy seal teams as prescribed by
their master chief marine units fbi
sniper teams at least
five nfl teams who have subscriptions
they are the exclusive hydration partner
to team usa weightlifting and on and on
you can try it risk free if you don't
like it element will give you your money
back no questions asked they have
extremely low
return rates element came up with a very
special offer for you my dear listeners
for a limited time you can claim a
free element sample pack you only cover
the cost of shipping
for u.s customers this means you can
receive an eight-count sample pack
for just five dollars simply go to drink
element dot com slash tim
that's drink lmnt dot com slash tim to
claim your free eight count sample pack
one more time that's drink lmnt dot com
slash tim for this exclusive offer
drinkelement.com
tim check it out
this episode is brought to you by all
form if you've been listening to this
podcast for a while you've probably
heard me talk about helix
sleep and their mattresses which i've
been using since 2017
i have two of them upstairs from where
i'm sitting at this moment
and now helix has gone beyond the
bedroom and started making
sofas they just launched a new company
called all form a-l-l-f-o-r-m and
they're making premium
customizable sofas and chairs shipped
right to your door at a fraction of the
cost of traditional stores
so i'm sitting in my living room right
now and it's entirely
all form furniture i've got two chairs
i've got an ottoman and i have an
l sectional couch and i'll come back to
that
you can pick your fabric they're all
spill stain and scratch resistant the
sofa color
the color of the legs the sofa size the
shape to make sure it's perfect for you
and your home
also all form arrives in just three to
seven days and you can assemble it all
yourself in a few minutes no tools
needed i was quite astonished by how
modular
and easy these things fit together kind
of like lego pieces they've got arm
chairs love seats all the way up to an
eight seat
sectional so there's something for
everyone you can also start small and
kind of build on top of it if you want
to get a smaller couch and then build
out on it which is actually in a way
what i did because i can turn
my l-sectional couch into a normal
straight couch and then with a separate
ottoman
in a matter of about 60 seconds it's
pretty rad so
i mentioned i have all these different
things in this room i use the natural
leg finish which is their lightest color
and i dig it i mean i've been using
these things hours and hours and hours
every single day so i am using what i
am sharing with you guys and if getting
a sofa without trying it in store sounds
risky
you don't need to worry all form sofas
are delivered directly to your home with
fast free shipping and you get 100 days
to decide if you want to keep it
that's more than three months and if you
don't love it they'll pick it up for
free and give you a full refund
your sofa frame also has a forever
warranty that's literally
forever so check it out take a look
they've got all sorts of cool stuff
to choose from i was skeptical and it
actually worked it worked much better
than i could have imagined and i'm very
very happy so to find your perfect sofa
check out allform.com
tim that's a l lform.com
tim all form is offering 20 off all
orders to you my dear listeners at
allforum.com
tim make sure to use the code tim at
checkout
that's allforum.com tim and use code tim
at checkout at this altitude i can run
flat out for a half mile before my hand
starts shaking
can i answer your personal questions
[Music]
i'm a cybernetic organism living tissue
over metal endoskeleton
hello boys and girls ladies and germs
this is tim ferriss and welcome to
another episode of
the tim ferriss show my guest today
is sulekha joad that's spelled
s-u-l-e-i-k-a
j-a-o-u-a-d lots of vowels
you can find her on instagram and
twitter at suleika jawad
she is the author of the new york times
best-selling memoir between
two kingdoms she wrote the emmy
award-winning new york times column
and video series life interrupted and
her reporting and essays have been
featured
in the new york times magazine the
atlantic vogue and npr among others
a highly sought after speaker her main
stage ted talk was one of the 10 most
popular of 2019
and has nearly 4 million views she's
also the creator of the isolation
journals
how i first became more familiar with
her work a community
creative project founded during the
coven 19 pandemic to help others convert
isolation
into artistic solitude more than 100 000
people from around the world
have joined you can find one of my
favorite prompts which i shared
on my blog last spring at team.log
forward slash
dialogue you can find her online at
sulekha jawad.com
on instagram twitter at the same salaika
jawad
and on facebook at sulekha jawad page
suleika welcome to the show thanks tim
i'm so excited to be here i'm so excited
to have you here
and as always there's an embarrassment
of riches in front of me
on many pages of notes and i was
drinking copious amounts of coffee
trying to figure out where to start
and i think where i would like to start
is with the vigil
now that's not going to mean anything to
anyone until we provide some context so
could you please describe
what the vigil is what am i referring to
the vigil
was a story i reported for new york
times magazine i think it was two or
three years ago
and i traveled to northern california to
a
maximum security prison and in that
prison
is one of the first prison hospices in
the country
which might sound wildly depressing
but it was truly one of the most
inspiring
two weeks of my life what makes the
prison hospice so unique
is that it's staffed by fellow
prisoners who've been trained in hospice
work and who are there
caring for their fellow prisoners who
are in the final days or weeks of their
lives
and i ended up following three
young men all three of them were in the
early 20s or
30s and for a lot of the guys who worked
in the hospice
their first encounter with mortality
was in the context of first or second
degree murder
and they were trying to find a sense of
redemption
and atonement through that work and i
was
struck not just by the
incredible compassion that they modeled
but a kind of restorative justice
that they were practicing in not just
taking care of themselves and reckoning
with their pasts
but quite literally sitting vigil
with fellow prisoners around the clock
and being
present in those most sacred final hours
how did that experience affect you
if it did it sounds like an immersive
experience
it uh entailed i imagine a lot of
observation
and lots of note taking
does anything come to mind that stuck
with you or that you
that stands out as a feeling you
experienced during that time
so i'm reminded of the great brian
stevenson's line
about how the worst thing we've ever
done doesn't define us and
at that point i think i was in my late
20s i walked into that
prison with my own set of preconceptions
or fears or anxieties about how that
process would go
and every single one of those was
upended
i remember setting up in the tv room
in the prison hospice with my tape
recorder
and by day two i had a long
line of men waiting outside the room to
be interviewed
and a lot of them weren't relevant
to the story necessarily but what i came
to understand in these conversations
was that most of these people had never
been interviewed before they'd never had
a chance to tell their stories
on their own terms and their own words a
lot of them
cried and i came to understand that it
was this
rare moment where vulnerability
could be shown and expressed especially
in an environment in which yeah
vulnerability is not only
seen as a form of weakness but it can
also
be a danger so whatever plans i had
for how i was going to report this story
went out the window
it was an experience of sitting and
listening and being
present unlike any other
reporting or or writing work i've done
in the past
and to be allowed in
those most vulnerable moments was
no small gift actually just a few months
ago one of the guys that i profiled
fernando merlo
who was given a life sentence at the age
of
18 was released from prison
in part because of that story and
the model and mate and and the
redemption
he fought so hard for and and achieved
during his time behind bars
and that conversation that i had while i
was reporting the story
still continues i still talk to fernando
and some of the other people
in the story and so they've really had
this unusual and long lasting
impact on my life you mentioned
encounters with mortality you have
certainly had
your own encounters with mortality which
we're going to explore
at some length not just yet before we
get there
just so people don't think i'm a
complete idiot
i did make a wise crack about how many
vowels are in your name in part because
before we started recording you made
that crack
it's clearly not check because check is
basically just
miscellaneous consonants and i say that
with czech blood so relax everybody
where does that name come from what is
the origin
story or what are the origins of your
name
so it was a name given to me by my
dad who is from tunisia and where i
still
hold a passport to and where most of my
family and my dad's side
lives it's actually in arabic but that
would be a whole
other pronunciation mess so i won't make
you call me that
for my parents my mama swifts they were
looking
for a name that they could pronounce in
all three of the languages that we speak
in our family
and then our home one that would sound
vaguely similar
in french and english and then arabic
but
like a lot of kids growing up i really
disliked my name
i remember in the fourth grade begging
my parents to let me legally change my
name to ashley
ashley which they thankfully
said no to but when you're a kid you
know the idea of being
unique is not necessarily a positive
you don't want to stand out and
my defining experience growing up
was being a misfit in every culture that
i was in
where did you grow up i was born
in new york city in the east village but
between the ages of 2 and 12
we moved constantly i lived in
switzerland i lived
in tunisia i lived in the u.s
and i went to i don't know five or six
different schools
why did you move so often my dad's a
professor
he taught comparative literature and
french literature
at a small school in upstate new york
and
every time he would get a sabbatical or
whenever
he had the opportunity they would both
decide to
go back to their homelands
but i think the the bigger truth is that
we were trying
to figure out as a family where we fit
especially
since we don't have family in the u.s
other than just
my parents and my brother and me but i
think like a lot of
mixed kids the notion of home
was an elusive concept in some ways it
still
is well let's talk about
if i may speculate here one of your
artistic homes
i i don't know how you think of it but
writing the craft of writing itself
and reflecting on the vigil i was struck
by
the strength of the lead the strength of
the opening and i know
well i'm being i don't want to give
myself too much credit here but i
can appreciate how difficult that is to
do well
because of how much volume you
will be able to sift through
with a paradox of choice to actually
then hone and craft
what is a compelling narrative and i
would love to know
if you had any particular influences or
teachers
who led you directly or indirectly to
writing
so i think the place that i always found
a sense of home
was in books i was a huge reader
i wrote but privately in the confines of
my journal
and it wasn't until i went to college
that i started thinking
about taking some writing classes i
actually
applied to the creative writing program
my freshman year at princeton and was
rejected
and took that rejection pretty
badly in a sense that it was i already
had enough
self-doubt and it was the outward
confirmation that i needed
that this probably wasn't a good idea
for me to pursue further other than just
in
my spare time but my junior year when i
was
sifting through the course catalog i saw
a journalism class that caught my eye
and it was called writing about war
and it was taught by a journalist named
zanassi kambanus
and the notion of writing about war from
princeton new jersey
you should paint a picture for people
who don't know what princeton new jersey
is like
it's pretty much the opposite of a
conflict zone strong
adjusted position yes the swarovski
crystal shop
next to the clothing shop where no
students can purchase anything except
for
a handful it is not a war zone
exactly but that was our assignment was
to find a way to
write a story from
or about a kind of war zone and so all
semester i was
racking my brain and trying to figure
out what i could possibly write
and i ended up writing a profile of a
classmate
who'd been a soldier in the israeli
defense forces
and who had gotten very seriously
injured in a suicide bombing on a train
station near her house when she was
about 18 years old
and she'd undergone something like a
dozen surgeries
and still had nerve damage from the
shrapnel
and so i sat with her for a couple of
hours and interviewed her
and toward the end of that interview i
asked her if she knew anything
about the suicide bomber as she called
him
and she said she'd never been able to
research
anything about him and that was because
she was
unwilling due to the sort of emotional
charge or i see yeah i think it had
obviously been a very traumatic event
for her and for her family
and so i asked her if she might be
comfortable with me
doing a little digging and learning more
about who he was
and she agreed and what i realized
was that this young man was from the
belata refugee camp
in the west bank which is a place i'd
actually visited the
semester before during a fall break
and so i ended up tracking down
this young man's mother's phone number
and skyping her
from my dorm room and what came out of
that were these two
side-by-side profiles of my friend
and the suicide bomber's mother who felt
a tremendous
amount of empathy for my friend
and and for the other victims of
what her son had done and
that experience really electrified me
the notion that from the limitations
of a college campus or even a dorm room
i could seek out two stories
two perspectives that you'd think might
never actually fit together and not only
pair them side by side but create a kind
of
dialogue between two people from from
very different worlds with
very different views and more than that
a sense of connection
hope you got a good grade that's a lot
of investigative legwork
for an undergrad writing assignment
was that effectively the term project
that was the final
deliverable or was that one of many
throughout the period of
this semester that was the term project
the final project
and it ended up winning
i think it's actually called the ferris
prize i don't
that no i do know i probably yeah
it's probably i'm guessing more of the
ferris wheel ferris with one s
uh but yes has nothing to do with with
me sadly i wish
and you know i only mentioned that prize
because it did the very
opposite that the rejection i'd received
as a freshman
did for me which was it gave me a sense
of confidence
and a sense that this might possibly be
something that i could pursue
and of course at that age i don't know
about you but i was so
porous i was so sensitive
to outward feedback in large part
because
i wasn't sure what it was that i wanted
to do it's not that i didn't know what i
was interested in but i just
couldn't quite bridge the gap between
what i found interesting and what might
actually be practical
or possible so let's take a closer look
at just two different experiences
that you just juxtaposed so you have the
rejection your freshman year and
please fact check this if i'm not
getting this right but my understanding
is you attended princeton
on scholarship full scholarship is that
i did i was on full financial aid
got it and you get there
you apply to this first
writing class or writing seminar you are
rejected
what then led you to apply again because
i can see some people
feeling summarily defeated and just
concluding this is not the path for me
and then not subsequently applying
to this later class for fear of being
rejected again so how did that come
about
i now need to fact check myself but from
what i remember the journalism class
did not require an application or if it
did
the barrier to entry was much slower but
i also think that
at that point i just spent this semester
abroad
in egypt i'd relearned my native tongue
of arabic and i felt
a sense of confidence not in my
writing abilities but confidence
in that i believed i i might have an
interesting
perspective to offer which was
you know my own lived experience growing
up in north africa
and the research and travels that i'd
done in the middle east
so it was less that i suddenly felt like
i'd become a stronger writer
or that i had new chops and more
that i i had a set of ideas and
experiences
that i believed had some worth did you
speak much arabic before going to
egypt so as a kid i spoke
french and arabic and when we moved back
to the us i was
about five or six years old and you know
i showed up
on the first day of kindergarten in
upstate new york
not speaking a word of english and what
ended up happening as i
became more fluent in english was that
arabic
sort of got wedged out and french was
the language we spoke at home english
was the language i spoke at school but
over time
i lost my arabic and so it was this very
strange experience when i started
studying arabic
as an undergrad and that i would read
certain words or certain words would be
uttered by the teacher
and somewhere deep in the recesses of my
memory
something would click in and i knew what
the word was
that's so cool and part of the reason i
ask is that
i've almost non-existent knowledge of
arabic but i spent a little bit of time
in jordan and a few other places
and in preparation for going
came to realize that not
all arabic is one arabic
you have modern standard arabic which is
kind of as i understand it more of kind
of this academic abstraction of sorts
that is used for just the simplicity of
universal teaching
but then you have levantine arabic
and then you have gulf arabic which then
is quite different in some aspects from
egyptian arabic which
produces or i should say egypt itself
produces a lot of the entertainment
right so there is a kind of saturation
of of maybe egyptian
arabic was that a stumbling block or was
it not i'm just imagining someone who
when they were a kid
learned and spoke english and say iowa
and then ends up doing like study abroad
to scotland and they're like oh
wow okay well i kind of think maybe i
get some of this i don't know how
different it is but was that
material for you or not so much it was
absolutely material for me so i was
familiar
with tunisian arabic and my
sophomore year of college i got a grant
to study
arabic and morocco and i remember my
first day
i went to a restaurant and i said
which in tunisia means could i have some
bread and
the waiter and the wait staff burst out
laughing and it turned out that the
tunisian word for bread was
a very derogatory term
for a part of the female anatomy
[Laughter]
oh that's that is a that's a gem wow
yeah
yeah so if you go to morocco don't say
the word taboona
yeah it's kind of like there are many
different types of spanish
and if you go to certain
spanish-speaking areas and you say you
want to coher
it doesn't translate terribly well but
it will get some good laughs
and i want listeners to realize part of
the reason i'm asking you about language
is in fact the same reason i'm asking
you a lot about
writing and that is that both are
reflections
of thinking and both affect thinking
and the lenses through which you look at
the world and then
translate that into communicating your
experience with the world so that's
i just want to take a step back to
explain to people why
all of these things in my mind are very
much
tied together and i want to fill in
also just a little gap and that is high
school
to princeton how does this happen
because
princeton's not the easiest school to
get into
and i don't know much about your journey
through high school so
i wasn't a very strong student
growing up in part because i'd shuffled
around to so many different schools
different grades and it wasn't until my
freshman year
of high school that something began to
click in for me
i'd been playing the double bass for
a couple of years and really
fell in love with the instrument my mom
had started me on piano
when i was four and was very strict
about me practicing and i absolutely
hated it but when i was
eight years old she'd given me the
option of picking a secondary
instrument and so in my eight-year-old
rebellious mind i decided to pick the
instrument that would inconvenience my
parents the most
genius which was this giant wooden
object
called the upright base and i fell in
love with it
pretty much from the first time that i
played it but
something about sitting alone in a
practice room
with my base for many hours i think
gave me a kind of discipline and focus
that i hadn't had but it also presented
a different path forward and i started
playing very competitively and you know
going to band camp and all the other
things that you do when you're into
music
as a teenager and that's what i thought
i was going to do i thought i was
going to become a classical musician
that i was going to play the bass
and then orchestra and when i was 16 i
got a scholarship to go to the juilliard
pre-college program
in new york city which is very exciting
and
also again very inconvenient for my
parents
because it entailed waking up at about
4am
every saturday driving me 45 minutes to
the train station
and taking a three and a half hour train
to new york city which allowed me to get
to juilliard's campus just in time for
my 9 am music theory class
and because of all the traveling and all
the performing
i was really struggling
to keep up with the long hours and
classes and schedule
of a public high school and so i ended
up
coming up with a deal with my parents
which was that i was going to drop out
of high school
and that in the place of high school i
was going to take
classes at the small liberal arts
college where my dad taught where i
could attend and take classes for free
which college was that skidmore college
yeah i know skidmore
so my plan at 16 because of course like
a lot of 16 year olds i thought i was
far more mature and sophisticated and
knew
far more than i actually did was
to study music and to go to conservatory
and that these classes i was taking
at skidmore were just gonna be the boxes
that i was gonna check to appease my
parents but what ended up happening was
that i
enrolled in some literature courses
and i started to write more seriously
and i was just like a sponge soaking up
as much as i could
what did writing more seriously look
like
what changed so i remember
loving the literature classes that i was
taking so much
that i actually started looking up the
english syllabus at different schools
in the region and assigning them to
myself and
in the course of that reading i remember
reading
in particular speak memory by vladimir
nabokov and trying to
write in his style and of course doing
it probably very
poorly with lots of purple prose
but i started um what do you mean by
purple prose
like overwritten flowery ornate
not necessarily long sentences yeah yeah
yeah garbage basically
still not the worst to try to model
right yeah exactly
exactly tough assignment but i like that
that was a self assignment
but i guess what i mean by writing more
seriously was moving from
just writing in a journal which is
something i'd always done
to actually trying different forms
writing poetry writing
sonnets and and prose poems writing
personal essays writing fiction
and really kind of exploring and
exercising
this new muscle and very consciously
trying to develop it
and so ultimately i came to the
conclusion
that i wanted to keep exercising those
muscles that i didn't just want to
study one thing and to sit in a practice
room for many many hours
a day but that i actually wanted to go
to college
although of course at that point you
know i didn't have a high school diploma
and i suddenly began to scramble
to figure out how to put together a
college application
and what that would look like you know
because both my parents
are not from the us they had no sense of
how to do that
so i ended up applying
early decision to princeton for two
reasons
one was because of the creative writing
faculty and the other was because
of the orchestra that they had and i
hope that
the proximity to new york city would
maybe allow me
to keep taking music lessons and keep
studying with my teacher
and so i wrote an essay
making a case for why even though i
hadn't gotten my high school diploma i'd
gotten
an equivalent if not deeper and better
education through this kind of
unconventional
program of music conservatory and taking
these different classes
but just so you have a sense of how
clueless i was
on the part of the application where
they ask you to list your
ap subjects i wrote down all the
classes i'd taken at skidmore like
modern dance
women and literature
because i thought well these are college
classes i don't know what an ap
is but it seems like these are
appropriate to list here
well the assigning to yourself
the mimicking of these various writing
styles and taking that more
seriously seems to have been possibly a
deciding factor
in getting accepted at princeton it
would seem
it was also the year where the dean said
that they were looking for more
green-haired students
and so i didn't have green hair but i
think i i
fit into whatever that that alternative
category might have been of an atypical
student but that first year in college
was really challenging
i had a kind of chip on my shoulder
i'm sure like a lot of other students
did because
i hadn't gone to
a fancy school and because i hadn't even
graduated
from my public school i felt
this need to make up that distance
and to work very hard to try to
catch up and to try to fill in some of
those gaps
in my education
just a quick thanks to one of our
sponsors and we'll be right back to the
show
this episode is brought to you by dry
farm wines i'm a wine drinker i love it
love a few glasses over meals with
friends that said i hate
hangovers it kills me often for multiple
days right now
all of the wine in my house is from dry
farm wines also for my last two book
launch parties
all the wine has been from dry farm
wines why is that
because in my personal experience their
wine means more fun with fewer
headaches dry farm wines only ships wine
that meet very stringent criteria
close to sugar-free so less than 0.15
grams per glass
lower alcohol less than 12.5 percent
alcohol additive free
there are more than 70 fda approved wine
making additives
the fewer the better in your wine lower
sulfites organic and produced by small
family farms
all dry farm wines are laboratory tested
for purity standards by certified
independent enologists
and all of their wines are backed by a
100 happiness promise they will either
replace or refund any wine you don't
love
last but not least i find delicious
wines i never would have found otherwise
so it's a lot of fun
saves me time and research and i have
fewer headaches other fans of dry farm
wines include the incredible doctor dom
d'agostino who's been on this podcast
very
popular guest you remember the guy who
did a 10-day fast and then
did 10 repetitions of deadlifts with 500
pounds that guy he drinks their wine
even when on a ketogenic
diet which can work dry farm wines is
offering you an extra bottle in your
first box for
a penny because it's alcohol it can't be
free find all the details
and collect your wine at
dryfarmwines.com
tim check it out dry farm wines dot com
tim and one more time i love this stuff
dryfarmwines.com
tim
now the award-winning new york times
column and video series
life interrupted is called
life interrupted why i mentioned
that you had encounters with mortality
could you please tell the story
of how you came to encounter your
mortality
i graduated from college with these
vague notions of wanting to become a war
correspondent or a foreign correspondent
but wasn't sure how to go about doing
that i think journalism unlike a lot of
careers doesn't have a clear point of
entry there's no
corporate ladder to climb no kind of
ideal
starter job and what i ended up doing
was
taking a job as a paralegal at a law
firm in france
and i was excited to get the chance to
live
abroad and and hoping to
find time to write and to begin putting
together some clips and
and figuring out what that path forward
might look like for me
but before i was able to do any of that
my life was interrupted it started
with a mysterious edge that blossomed
into all kinds of symptoms
and ultimately almost exactly a year
after i graduated
i was diagnosed with an aggressive form
of leukemia and it was one of those
bifurcating moments
where your life fractures there's
a before and there's an after
and even though i didn't know much about
my diagnosis
or what the treatment would look like i
understood
that i would never be the same well walk
us through
the first say month of
i suppose the or the first day
you can pick the time frame of your
hospitalization
i remember hoping
maybe naively maybe even a little
arrogantly that this was gonna be a
short
sojourn in the kingdom of the sick
i wasn't planning to unpack my bags to
get too comfortable
i resisted even you know the label
of cancer patient and was determined
to as much as was possible
remain the person i'd been and to
somehow
figure out how to make something useful
out of
what had happened and so i was admitted
to the hospital
for what was supposed to be a two-week
stay and what ended up being
an almost two-month stay and i remember
packing a suitcase full of books
i packed war and peace thinking to
myself this is one of those books
that i've never read and this is finally
you know the time
to actually read it and to catch up on
doing some of these things that i
haven't
had the time to do but of course
i never ended up reading a single one of
those books i still have yet to read
war and peace and whatever notions i had
about what illness was going to be like
pretty much imploded within
my first week in the hospital i was in
medical isolation i called it my bubble
i wasn't allowed to leave my room i
couldn't open a window and anyone who
entered
had to suit up and the equivalent of
a hazmat suit or what looked like a
beekeeper suit
with gloves and a face mask and a
surgical gown
and at some point during that summer
i learned that not only had the
standard chemotherapy treatments not
worked for me
but that my leukemia had become much
more aggressive
and that at that point my only options
were
experimental clinical trials and
that i think more than the diagnosis
itself
was profoundly devastating it was
shocking
especially at an age where youth and
health
are supposed to go hand in hand even if
you don't know who you are
or what you're going to do with your
life you tell yourself you have time
and suddenly that relationship to time
for me
change pretty abruptly i didn't have
time
i didn't have the option of
experimenting and taking different jobs
and
traveling the world or whatever those
big and small milestones are
of early adulthood war and peace also
unread by yours truly uh i hate to admit
it
there there are there's certain books
that travel
with me from place to place year to year
decade to decade like
i'm sorry edward but edward tufte's
books and they're just sort of these
these these indications of where i
maybe aspire to be at some point in the
future but i never quite get to that
future
nonetheless i did read about a few
books that seem to have been impactful
during this experience and i'm going to
explore multiple facets of this
experience because i'm very very
interested
a few of the books that have come up
and please confirm deny or
modify as needed i'm going to
mispronounce this is it audrey lords the
cancer journals
john green's the fault in our stars
which probably be more familiar
to people and then i read that your true
quote unquote sick girl bible was
lucy greeley's autobiography of a face
is that accurate so far yes that is
what i'm very impressed by your research
also oh some thanks to my team who helps
with
with these things but the autobiography
of a face or autobiography of a face
why was that so impactful or why did
that book
stand out so i should just say that
it took me a while to arrive to those
books
in those first couple of months you know
i really had to
shed that kind of type a
anxiety of accomplishment
because everything felt difficult i
barely had the energy to speak
or walk much less down and read
and instead i was busy setting the world
record
for the number of grey's anatomy
episodes watched consecutively
so that's what i did for my first couple
of months
and i very much resisted
reading any cancer related literature
because when i did i often found that
those books
were written from the perspective of
someone who
survived and who was many years out or
i'd read about these cancer survivors
who had done incredible
things they'd gone on to start research
foundations or to run
ultra marathons and that made me
feel bad about the way i was
experiencing my illness
i think there's a lot of pressure
especially as a cancer patient to be
brave to be stoic to be
graceful to be someone who suffers well
and it wasn't until a couple months into
that experience
that i began to look for
different kinds of books and the reason
i began
to search for those books is because
of that profound sense of isolation i
could no longer relate to my healthy
friends
but at 22 you know i was a year too old
for pediatrics
but often decades younger than most of
the other patients
in the cancer award so i didn't
necessarily
relate to my fellow patients at least
not the ones i met at first what was
your total stay time
in the hospital roughly i was
in treatment for four years but that
first year i spent about
eight months of it in the hospital and
in medical isolation
and so at some point i started to
seek out stories
that held a kind of resonance that
were written from the trenches whether
they were
fiction or memoir and the first book of
that genre that i read was the fault in
our stars
which is about two teenagers who fall in
love
and spoiler alert die at the end
but it was also an incredibly funny book
it was
full of humor and and full of the
typical
coming-of-age stuff that any young
person
lives and and that was a really
important book for me
and not only because it held all the
kind of nuances
of that experience but because it
exploded
into the mainstream and the fact
that a book about two young
cancer patients could become the kind of
international sensation that it did
felt like no small gift at a time when
it felt like i was really
living in the shadows and that there was
so much
of that experience that wasn't known or
that was
awkward or complicated to talk about and
so that led me on this journey
of reading these other books of
reading lucy grilli's autobiography of a
face of really
seeking out writers who were giving ink
to the experience of illness in a way
that felt fresh
and true and perspective-altering
what does the title autobiography of a
face
refer to or how does that pertain to the
story
within lucy's book so lucy grilli was
this
incredible poet and as a kid she'd had
a form of bone cancer called ewing
sarcoma
and she survived that cancer but because
of the surgeries and the radiation that
she'd had
to her jaw she had to have a number
of different surgeries over the course
of her life that left her disfigured
and so the book is less about the
experience of cancer
than it is about interrogating
beauty and living
with her face and the kind of long-term
imprints of that experience across her
whole life
and i was really struck by that
book especially later as i began to
emerge from cancer treatment and as i
began to reckon with the imprints of my
own illness on my body and my life and
my sense of self
what were some of those imprints let's
just say
to begin on your body post
hospitalization
so when i finished treatment i still had
a port
which looks like a little hockey puck
under the skin below my my right
collarbone i had scars
i was infertile as a result of the
chemotherapy
that i did i had extreme fatigue
and a compromised immune system because
of my bone marrow transplant that i
underwent
and all of those symptoms were
confusing and difficult for me
to figure out how to carry because i
think i was so
fixated on a cure that
when the cure actually came
i wasn't prepared for the ongoingness
of illness or really of living any sort
of
trauma and i had this notion that i was
quickly and eagerly and organically
going to
fold back into the rhythms of living
but instead i found myself grappling
with this dissonance between
what should be and what was on paper i
no longer had cancer
off paper i couldn't have felt further
from being
the healthy happy 27 year old
woman that i'd expected to be on the
other end of that
it's based on some of the reading that
that i've done and also
uh in your your ted talk you had four
hour naps
in the middle of some days you still had
to
make visits or you did make visits at
least to the
er at points i'm curious
to hear how you related to expectations
of you perhaps so outside of
sort of the physical aspect did you feel
there were certain expectations of you
after let's just call it
beating cancer and then a dissonance
between
sort of the the reality of your
experience and what was expected
of you if that question makes any sense
absolutely
i remember the day i was discharged
from the hospital and was finally done
with these four years
of treatment getting a slew of text
messages
congratulating me on being done and that
seemed to
imply an end point that i very much
wanted
but didn't feel necessarily true or
accurate because there were so many
unanswered questions that i realized i
suddenly needed to figure out like the
ones you just named
how do i hold down a job if i need to
nap for four hours in the day
how do you begin to date when you're
coming out of an experience like this
and you still have a port in your chest
where do you even
or do you bring up a cancer diagnosis
without
potentially scaring somebody away is it
responsible for me to consider long-term
commitments
like marriage or children given my
high likelihood of relapse you know
those were the questions i was swimming
around in but the other piece of it that
i began to grapple with are the ways in
which the hero's
journey arc is projected onto
survivors there's this notion that when
you
emerge from
a trial or a big trauma
you are better braver
stronger for what you've been through
but i didn't feel
brave i didn't feel strong i felt
wrecked by this experience and
had no idea who i was or how to find my
way
forward and what i'd expected to be
the kind of final act of
this illness experience which was being
cured was actually
the beginning of a very different kind
of
healing please say more
i would like to encourage you to
continue what do you mean by that
in that first year after treatment i was
hell-bent on moving on from this
experience
i wanted to be
a quote unquote normal young person and
i remember
looking to my friends almost with an
anthropological
sort of eye thinking to myself like what
does a normal 27 year old do
in trying to do those things almost as
if i was kind of play acting
and you know i'd go out dancing
with friends and then pay for it with
three days
in bed i would try to
force myself to write about something
other than illness to come up with
something new and i just couldn't
and what i came to understand is that
moving on is a myth you don't get to
compartmentalize your most difficult
passages
and stove them in the past you don't get
to skip
over the hard work of healing and
grieving and recovering and really
uncovering
who you are in the wake of that and that
instead i was going to have to learn to
move
forward with this experience with
these imprints on my body and my mind
and to learn how to integrate them in my
present
so i started thinking about the language
of ritual and the rules
of rights of passage and these
transitional moments we have
birthdays and funerals and weddings and
bar mitzvahs these morning periods
yeah and morning periods these
ritualized
ceremonies that allow us to shoulder
complicated feelings that help us
cross the distance between no longer and
not yet and what i realized was
that there is no 12-step program there
is no
right of passage for when you
survive a trauma like illness and that i
was going to have to
create one for my own and so that's what
i did
as tim takes a long inhale because
there's so many
so many questions i want to ask i don't
want to interrupt your train of thought
but you mentioned no one gets to skip
the hard work of grieving recovering
and or in some senses uncovering the
trauma or the difficulty
through which they have passed i would
love to hear
[Music]
what type of work whether it ended up
being hard or otherwise
ended up in retrospect being really
valuable was it were there any
particular
things you did types of therapy you
experimented with
anything at all that really seemed to
help
with those check boxes
these are the things that must be done
before you can pass go you don't get to
skip these seven steps
was there anything that really stood out
as valuable
or helpful in terms of that work
so the truth is i didn't do much of that
work that first year
i had done therapy while i was sick i
had gone
to support groups for young adults with
cancer
but in the aftermath of that experience
because
of that projection that this was
supposed to be
done i didn't have in place those same
kinds of support systems and structures
i think when someone gets diagnosed or
when someone loses a loved one
if you're lucky to have friends and
family everyone rallies around you
in that moment of acute distress but in
my experience and and
the experiences of so many other people
that i've befriended or interviewed it's
it's the quieter weeks and months after
that are the hardest
because you don't have the cavalry
running after you and you're left to
your own devices
and so all those sources
of support that i had created for myself
or sought out in treatment i no longer
had
in the wake of treatment and so i really
had to
invent my own but this notion of of
recovery
is something that i spent a lot of time
reflecting on the word recovery implies
a return to something
and i think in that first year i was
really trying
to return to the person i'd been
pre-diagnosis and very quickly realized
that that person
no longer existed and that though the
word
may be implied otherwise recovering
wasn't about
a return to the old it was a kind of
brute terrifying act of discovery and
what was helpful was i met a doctor who
was
i was actually interviewing for a story
and we got to talking and i explained to
him some of the things i've been
struggling with and he said to me
it sounds like you have post-traumatic
stress disorder
you have ptsd and that was a revelation
to me
because i thought of ptsd as something
that's
reserved for veterans returning from war
or someone
who has experienced a kind of violence
it hadn't occurred to me that it also
applied to emerging from
a long period of life-threatening
illness
and once i actually understood
what it was that i was feeling once i
removed
any expectations of what this
post-cancer
experience was going to be like and i
actually was able to confront
the facts of what was happening face
forward
then i actually began to create a plan
for myself
what did that plan look like and was it
mostly focused then at that point on the
present state awareness of this possible
diagnosis
of ptsd so rather than being trapped in
the past
trying to revert to this
pre-illness version of yourself that no
longer existed
did the plan focus then on
this diagnosis or possible diagnosis of
ptsd what did it look like
the simplest way for me to say is that i
understood
i needed time to heal which wasn't
something that i had allowed myself i'd
been
pushing myself to figure out what i was
going to do next and
to kind of get back into the motions of
living immediately
but more than that what i understood was
that i needed to learn
how to feel safe again in my own body i
write in the book that
when the ceiling caves in on you you no
longer
assume structural stability you have to
learn to live along fault lines and so
that really
became my work i wanted to
feel safe in my body i wanted
to learn to become my own caregiver
after years of being dependent on other
caregivers
and more than anything i wanted to
carve out the time and space to figure
out
who i was and what that path forward was
going to look like for me
so what i did was i started by
confronting
a smaller fear but still a pretty
significant fear for me
which was learning how to drive um
and so that's what i did i learned how
to drive
and as i began learning how to drive
i started dreaming of going on a long
road trip
and as i began dreaming of that i began
to imagine
a solo cross-country road trip
and i didn't just want to go on some
kind of touristy boondoggle but i was
really
seeking out people who could offer
guidance
and this strange kind of limbo in
between place that i found myself in
and so i ended up making a list of about
22 strangers all of whom had
written to me in response to my column
about all kinds
of reckonings and interruptions in their
own life
and that's what i set out to do i had
this
newly minted driver's license which i'd
had for about a month i
rented out my apartment and
used the funds from that to pay for my
road trip
and i reached out to all of these
different people to let them know i'd
love to meet
face to face and i left home
into the unknown also
just to explain perhaps
the title of the book so you mentioned
this in between space
i think you are a master of in-between
spaces in the sense that
i know you've written that you're always
interested in traveling to where the
silence is
and detecting that and interrogating
that not necessarily in an aggressive
way the
title between two kingdoms comes from
an observation in is it susan sontag's
illness
as metaphor quote everyone who is born
holds dual citizenship in the kingdom of
the well
and in the kingdom of the sick
and i suppose what's left out of that is
that there is a spectrum between those
two points right it's not just
a binary one or the other at least in
your lived experience
and is there anything you'd like to to
add
to selecting that as the title for the
memoir
yeah i mean i think that kind of binary
thinking especially as
we live longer and longer
lives means that that border is porous
and that much of us end up spending our
lives somewhere
between the two and so
removing that sense that i had to be a
denizen of
one or the other and allowing myself to
exist
in that messy middle i used to think of
it as the kind of wilderness
of survivorship was where i was
when i left for that road trip and my
hope
was that that trip and the people
i met along the way would form a kind of
breadcrumb path back toward
some semblance of existing among the
living
so to recap you learn to drive at 27
around one month before a 15 000 mile
solo road trip which of course
sounds totally improbable but
this this is a real story and i wanted
to
before we get to that because i think
these things are
in some ways interrelated i wanted to
ask
first how you landed your new york times
column
because that in some ways was
the birthplace or the connective tissue
that then
brought these people into your life
in a way that would connect into this
road trip so how did
you land the new york times column at
some point during that first year of
treatment my friends and family came up
with the idea of doing something called
the hundred day project
and the concept was really simple we
were each gonna pick our own project
and do something creative every day for
100 days
so my dad wrote a hundred childhood
memories
about growing up in tunisia that he
compiled into a little booklet
and gave to me my mom who's an
artist painted a ceramic tile every day
for a hundred days that she
assembled into a shield and
hung above my bed and told me it had
protective powers and so for my hundred
day project
i decided to keep the stakes very low
and i returned to the thing i've always
done in difficult
moments which was journaling and i
created a couple
rules for myself the first was that i
had to do it every day
but that it didn't matter if the quality
was any good and it didn't matter
how long my journal entries were so
sometimes it was
several pages often it was a paragraph
occasionally it was one word sometimes
it was just the f word
but that's what i did
i journaled every day for 100 days and
something interesting began to happen
during that journaling process i found
myself
observing my hospital room and the world
around me in a different sort of way i
was
recording snippets of conversations
between the nurses by the coffee station
i was
writing about the different patients i
was meeting
i was jotting down funny little
anecdotes that would come up
and i was writing about more serious
topics about the ones
that made me feel uncomfortable or
ashamed i've read about
the infertility i wrote about the
experience of falling
in love while falling sick i wrote about
navigating our insane
healthcare system and by the end of that
i realized that even though
i couldn't be a journalist in the way
that maybe i'd imagined
graduating from college i wasn't going
to be a war correspondent or a foreign
correspondent
i was in fact reporting
from the front lines of my hospital bed
on a different kind of conflict zone
and that project was really what became
the source material
for the column but because i'd never
been published before
and because i was
you know 23 at that point like the good
millennial
that i was i first started by creating a
blog
which felt manageable and so that's what
i did i watched youtube videos
and figured out how to put together a
very simple
blog and i started to write and to take
it seriously and to treat it
as a job and it felt really good to have
a job to do
other than just being a patient and
about two weeks later after i started
this blog
it had been circulated and
had racked up a significant number of
views or at least
what felt significant to me because i'd
gone into this whole thing
thinking that maybe my parents and my
grandmother and a couple of friends
would read it
i received a phone call from an editor
at the new york times asking me if i
might want to write
an essay and i paused
and very politely thanked her
and told her that i wasn't interested in
writing an essay
didn't see that coming okay continue
and i should just back up and say that
at that point
i was about two months out from a bone
marrow transplant
and a bone marrow transplant is this
incredibly risky
procedure and my doctors had told me
that i had about a
35 chance of long-term survival
and so that just to give you the context
of the frame of
mind that i was in so
i took a deep breath and i told this
editor
that what i actually wanted to do was to
write
a weekly column to write from
the trenches of treatment without
knowing
how my story was going to end and
to really give ink to that experience
of illness and youth and then i went on
and said
you know maybe if there could be a video
component that would be really cool too
because i know how hard it can be to
read when you're sick and i want to make
this project as accessible as possible
and i went on and on and on
and stopped and and was immediately
horrified
by everything that i just blurted out
because all of this of course would have
seemed
incredibly presumptuous to pre-diagnosis
me pre-diagnosis me would have been
grateful for you know a fact-checking
position
or an unpaid internship but the truth
was that i didn't
have the health or the time
to pursue those kinds of things
and in a strange way my circumstances
and my cancer and my prognosis had made
me
brazen and
the editor was quiet for a minute and
said all right
we'll try it for a couple of
installments and see how it goes
that is an amazing and my immediate
thought was oh
now i need to actually figure out how to
pull this off
i wasn't expecting that i love this
story for so many reasons
and it highlights a few things for me
number one is that
by creating a blog and beginning to
publish
and take it seriously you were
acting as a professional does that make
sense like you were
treating it as a professional would even
though you weren't
getting paid at the time and this is
this is something
steven pressfield talks about quite a
bit but it's a really
non-trivial sort of phase shift and
this might sound ludicrous but it
doesn't surprise me that you had someone
reach out to you
from an outlet after making that that
shift
and closely related to that is you don't
always have to work
your way up kind of rung by rung
sometimes you can just
ninja warrior your way over five or six
rungs
and a lot of that comes down to
whether we're looking at your your
application to princeton
or asking in this case for a column
it's reaching for what you want and
asking for what you want
and that's just such a a wonderful
affirmation of the value of doing those
two things and then
not to make this seem like you know one
trick
you then decide to learn to drive
and not to take a trip to the mall 30
minutes away
maybe that too but to do 15 000 miles
solo and you're using the relationships
that had emerged
from this column as sort of the
tentative
connective points to lead you through
the country so
i think it's 20 plus people so we're not
going to necessarily
talk about all of them but could you
give us a sense
of this group by painting a picture of a
few of them
the column launched my first week in the
bone marrow transplant unit
and i'm not sure that i'd given
much thought to what would come of it
because of the nature of my illness and
my prognosis i wasn't
thinking very far ahead i was truly
trying to survive each day and in fact
the future had become a very scary place
for me because i didn't know
if i would get to exist in the future so
i was purely focused on the work
there's a photo of me in the bone marrow
transplant unit
where i have a vomit bucket under one
arm
and i have my laptop under the other arm
and i'm
crying not because of the side effects
of the chemo are because i'm about to
have this
terrifying procedure but because i'm
late for a deadline
which was such a you know a healthy
re-orienting of of my anxieties
in that moment but what i didn't expect
when that first column
and video launched was this sense of
connection and possibility i would feel
to the world outside my windows and
that first day i received so many
letters from strangers around the world
i received
an email from a man who
was also undergoing a bone marrow
transplant for leukemia and happened to
be in the room
right next door to my hospital room and
we couldn't meet because we're both in
medical isolation and the germ risk was
too high but one day
as i was being rolled out of my room to
get a ct
scan i passed his door and i knocked on
the little window
and we waved and just that
moment of connection the fact of knowing
that there was someone else who was
living
what i was living gave me a source of
strength and a sense of community that
sustained me
throughout that bone marrow transplant
process but that experience was one that
i had with
so many people and not just with people
who were undergoing cancer treatment
i heard from a high school teacher
in california named catherine who'd lost
her son
to suicide a few years earlier i heard
from a family of survivalist ranchers
in montana i heard from
a young man on
death row in texas who'd never been sick
a day in his life he did
a thousand push-ups just as his warm-up
to start off each morning
who related to that experience of
isolation
and of facing mortality even though it
was in a very
different context and so those were the
people
i ended up going to visit and what i'd
done over the years of writing these
columns was
that i printed out the emails or the
messages
that really impacted me and i started
keeping them in a little
wooden box because i knew i wanted to be
able to return to them
and so those letters and that wooden box
became my itinerary for the road trip
one of the examples you gave stands out
a bit for me
i can imagine in most cases common
threads
of perhaps reflecting on mortality
the survivalists in montana jump out as
perhaps the black sheep of the bunch
what did they
say or what did one of them say in the
writing in the letter that was sent to
you
if you if you remember it was actually
from a woman
who goes by the nickname salsa um who
i had yeah of course
who i very briefly met at first descents
which is this incredible nonprofit that
offers
outdoor adventure trips for young adults
with cancer and she had been the
volunteer camp
mom who was charged with cooking and
making sure we were yeah well fed and
and nurtured for
for a week at camp and i
loved her immediately in part because
she kept
a bottle of hooch as she called it and a
little
purse inscribed or embroidered with
prayer scripture
but shortly after that trip at camp i'd
ended up in the hospital and she had
sent me this beautiful package uh with a
letter in it
inviting me to come visit her and her
family
on the ranch in montana and and to ride
the range
on horseback when i was well
again and so i'd kept that letter and
she went you know she didn't
fall into the category of a stranger
because we'd met
but i'd kept that letter because at that
time the possibility of traveling of
riding on horseback of going to montana
seemed
so far away but i would kind of daydream
about it
and so she and her family were
definitely one of the more
eventful stops on this road trip
but even though we couldn't have come
from
more different worlds and backgrounds
while i was there in montana i was
struck by this sense of
community they built at the end of my
time there
one of the ranchers said to me so we've
been talking and
you can be on our list and i was like
what list is that and he said our list
of people who can join us in end times
and he went on to say we've learned from
this last week
that you have pretty much no practical
skills
but you can you can be your scribe
because everyone needs to have a job and
i said i'll take that
it's better than court jester i suppose
exactly
it's really remarkable and i suppose on
some level
not surprising if we take the time to
let it sink in
how much shared humanity there is across
a group as completely
sort of heterogeneous as the one that
you is the one that you visited
right i mean despite all the obvious
differences how much
connectivity there is and i also i just
wanted to take a moment
to mention again one organization that
you mentioned and i think it's
uh first descents yeah and their website
is firstdissents.org
i i'm actually a huge fan of this
nonprofit so i'm glad that you mentioned
it and
the the simple description first a sense
provides life-changing outdoor
adventures for young adults
so 18 to 39 impacted by cancer and other
serious health conditions
it's uh it's a really remarkable
outstanding non-profit so i suggest
people check out firstasense.org
what did you find your
experience to be of the road trip
compared to your expectations
or hopes how did things most
differ well let me just start by saying
that i i began my road trip in new york
city
more specifically in midtown
and the first five minutes of my road
trip were
the most terrifying five minutes of my
life
which is saying a lot given what i just
been through
i remember twisting the keys in the
ignition
putting my my turn signal on i had
willie nelson's on the road again
playing i was really trying to like
set the vibe for myself
and i turned on to 9th avenue and i saw
this man
out of the corner of my eye in the
bicycle lane waving
his hands at me flapping them and i
thought
that's strange but then again weird
things happen in new york city all the
time
and i kept driving and suddenly i heard
this
chorus of car horns and i looked up and
realized
all the traffic was coming in my
direction
and that i was driving through a one-way
avenue
so i did the world's most dramatic
u-turn
and pulled over and my hands were
shaking and i thought to myself
i am certainly not a good enough driver
to be doing this
i don't think i'm well enough to be
doing this
what am i thinking i'm about to go visit
a bunch of people most of whom i've
never met before but there was also
this sense that if i stayed
i was going to stay
in that small stuck bubble
that i'd grown accustomed to living in i
was terrified of everything weirdly
after spending years in the hospital i'd
grown comfortable there i understood how
that world
worked it was the outside world that was
frightening to me and i knew in that
moment
that i had a choice i could either stay
in that stuck place um
and that you know even though it felt
safe it was still
a small stuck place or i could thrust
myself
into the bigger expanses of the world
and try to figure out what was on the
other side
of that fear and so it wasn't really a
choice
got it it was a ready fire aim scenario
right in the sense that you felt like it
was a
unnecessary step
to reach for something outside of the
stuckness
if that's a decent way to put it and you
know one uh
one thing i just want to mention you
you've referred to your time in the
hospital
as your incanseration right obviously a
play on incarceration
and that feeling of comfort
even with an environment that most would
consider very uncomfortable
in your case the hospital but in the
case of incarceration
prison is a very apt comparison and
pairing because
a lot of folks who are imprisoned become
very
accustomed to life in prison and
it might surprise listeners to know that
there are actually some people
who request to have their sentences
extended
because they fear going back into the
world not having tools not knowing how
to cope and then ending back
up in jail for even worse charges so i
just wanted to mention that as an aside
there's a
documentary i believe the title is the
artist and the thief
that uh showcases an example of that i
just want to say that
i'm so glad you brought that up because
you know that loss
stuck here was
a year of great depression for me
of great shame because i knew that i was
one of the lucky ones
and in my darkest moments i remember
wishing that i was still sick
or that i would get sick again not
because i wanted to have leukemia of
course
but because i missed the hospital's
ecosystem
i missed its inhabitants i understood
them it was
being on the outside being among the
healthy
that really made me feel like an
imposter
and that sense of missing something that
you shouldn't miss
was so unsettling to me and i remembered
you know at my very
sickest thinking to myself if
i'm going to survive this it has to be
to live a good life
a meaningful life a happy one but i
wasn't doing that i was doing
the very opposite of that and i knew
that i couldn't continue
on the way i was and so when i say stuck
i worry
that sounds light for what i was feeling
but it really
it really kind of bordered on a sense of
desperation
a feeling of i cannot continue on like
this
i need to find a different way forward
did the road trip
provide you with that or did it provide
you with some breadcrumbs that led
in a direction that provided you with
some optimism i'm just
wondering and all said and done fifteen
thousand miles later
uh were you happy that you'd done it i
know that's a lot of questions in one so
you can pick
however whichever you want to grab onto
it's a terrible habit i have of asking
17 part questions i think
to sit alone with your thoughts in a car
for many days many hours as it
can feel like a torturous form of
self-experimentation
and it definitely felt that way in the
beginning it was also
really physically challenging for me in
those early weeks on the road i would
drive
for two hours or three hours and be so
wrecked with
fatigue that i'd pull over and park in a
mcdonald's
parking lot to nap and so i was making
very slow
progress but the interesting thing about
being on
on this road trip for as long as i was
and i was on the road for roughly about
a hundred days
was that i started to feel better and
not in the sense
that these long-term permanent side
effects of my illness
disappeared they didn't you know that
fatigue that compromise immune system
chased me across state lines but i began
to learn to work with my limitations
and to accept them and
every day i would drive a little further
and a little
longer before i would do my mcdonald's
parking lot nap
i was camping by myself between these
different stops to visit the people on
my list
and that in and of itself was its own
edifying experience i was almost
modeling the kind of independence that i
did not have
and forcing myself through a kind of
self-imposed exposure therapy
to learn that i could
be alone that i could take care of
myself
that i could even camp in the woods and
be okay
but it was the conversations that really
i think made this trip so meaningful
and each of those people i call them my
road guardians
illuminated a different
aspect of what it means to be in that
aftermath of a trauma i'm reminded of a
line
by viktor frankl he says between
stimulus and
response there is a space and that space
is our power to choose a response
and our response lies our growth and our
freedom
and so each of those people that i
visited
had essentially chosen
a different and interesting response
to the stimulus whatever that was for
them illness or some other kind of
heartbreak that had brought them to the
floor
and so learning from them
practicing and and building those
muscles
of independence of being out in the
world on my own two feet
uh was the best possible thing i could
have done for myself
and and to this day i say that road trip
was
the best decision that i i've made in my
life
and interestingly you know my parents a
lot of people
said to them when i left for the road
aren't you worried about her doing this
it seems like a completely
terrible irresponsible idea
and my mom took her credit said of
course i'm worried
about her going on a road trip
especially as a new driver
but that's exactly what you should be
doing in your 20s
you should be keeping your parents up at
night because
you're going on a road trip and it's so
nice to have
normal parent worries and so
their support i think empowered me to do
this thing that felt
scary pretty much every step of the way
and until i got to the last third of the
trip
and really started to kind of relax into
driving and
and to feel a new fun sense of
confidence and
you know by the end of that road trip i
didn't feel
necessarily like i'd found my way back
to the kingdom of the well so to speak
but instead
i felt like i had learned to make a kind
of
home in the wilderness of the in between
and i felt like
i had stepped into a new iteration of
self
that allowed for my past
and my present to kind of come together
and coalesce what advice would you give
to someone
who is in some form of
darkness or stuckness and
again not i don't use the term
stuck or stuckness in a minimizing way
that can be when one is in such a place
and i've been in such a place although
not because of life-threatening illness
it can really
feel like the weight of the world is
upon you and there there's
there's kind of no exit available
if you were giving advice to say a group
of
i'm just imagining 30 people right so
they're all gonna have different life
circumstances some could take a road
trip
some probably couldn't take a road trip
but they were looking to
feel better whatever that might mean
what advice might you give to them what
might you say to them
i'll share two things the first
is a journaling
prompt that i use when i'm in that place
of stuckness or darkness
because i think when you when you're in
that place
it's impossible to imagine
a light beyond it so what i've done
in those moments is i actually make a
list
of all the hard things i've survived and
the reason that i do that
is because i need to remind myself
of my and my body's proven
track record of resilience so i'll
literally jot down every difficult thing
i've survived
big or small and just the act of writing
those
down brings forth that kind of muscle
memory
that trust that you've moved through
difficult passages before
and that you can again and the second
thing i'll say
is i don't know about you tim but like i
was raised in a
pull yourself up by the bootstraps type
of house
where the notion of tough skin was very
much something
to be acquired and desired
but i've found that that my own kind of
tough skin especially in those moments
of darkness is unhelpful
as much as i want to kind of armor
myself
or not allow myself to wallow
in those moments i've become an
advocate for a different approach which
is a kind of
tender skin approach of trying to
allow myself not just to be vulnerable
but to share that vulnerability
and so in a way for me the road trip
aside just having these conversations
with people who had lived
some version of that darkness
to be able to speak
the unvarnished truth of what i was
feeling
without having any pretense of
armor or toughness was
really the thing i think that helped me
get through
that moment and that's helped me get
through
so many other difficult moments because
there's a really
beautiful thing that happens when you
meet someone
with your vulnerability which is that it
creates a reverberation
and that vulnerability begets
vulnerability
begets vulnerability and i think it
allows for
an intimacy and a sense of
connection that you can't have when
you're trying to mask
the kind of painful or ugly parts of
yourself
and you know i'm reminded of something
nadia boltz weber
says about shame which is that that
sunlight is the best
disinfectant for shame and i would say
that that sunlight and vulnerability
is the best disinfectant for darkness
it ceases to be a terrible
private experience when you hold it up
to the light and when you see it
you know refracted in someone else's
experience
do you still have a journaling practice
i do
could you describe what that looks like
and that might seem like a hard left to
people listening or like jesus tim that
was
really not very subtle but i think these
might tie together and that's part of
why
i bring it up because literally to my
left about a foot and a half away
is a copy of the morning pages journal
the artist's way morning pages journal
by julia cameron and the practice of
morning pages which is one type of
journaling
is really as i believe julia describes
it
to provide spiritual windshield wipers
in so much as it's really just to take
the things that are rattling around
inside your mind that are
disabling or muddying the waters and to
fix them on paper like a fly in the
amber so that you can
then move on with your day so in a sense
like being vulnerable
even though it is from my eyes only
i find to be tremendously therapeutic
but there are
many different ways to journal it's one
way that i journal i would
love to hear more about what your
journal
and journaling practice looks like i've
been keeping a journal
pretty much since i was old enough to
hold a pen
and part of why i've
cut this practice is exactly what you're
saying it's this
one rare space where you get to show up
as your
most unedited self and the stakes are
very low because
it's for your eyes only and
i find that in writing in a journal
i open up a dialogue
with the self it's a space where you can
examine things
big or small and so i journal every day
it's the first thing i do
i wake up i let my dogs out into the
backyard and i make myself a cup of
coffee
and i write in my journal and i like to
write by hand
because there's no backspace bar
there's no possibility of editing you
have to
follow the line of thought through to
its end without worrying if it's
dumb or if it makes any sense i actually
do
most of my first drafts in my journal
so that i can kind of trick my brain out
of that space of thinking oh my gosh i'm
writing for a publication or i'm
writing for a deadline to that quieter
space of i'm exploring
and i'm experimenting and i can
follow an idea without worrying about
where it's going to lead me
so i use the journal for all kinds of
things i also
this might feel a little woo-woo to some
of your listeners
but you know i'm a big list fan and
probably like some of your listeners i
have very long
to-do lists that i keep for myself but
before i get to my to-do list
in my journal i often start by writing a
to feel list
and the reason i do that is because i
think
there's a way in which otherwise i kind
of tumble
into my tasks for the day head first
without a clear sense of intention and
that to feel this is really
a remnant of when i was sick when i had
about
three hours of usable energy in the day
which meant that i had to get very
specific about what i wanted to do in
those three hours
and who i wanted to spend them with and
what it was that i wanted
to feel could you give any examples of
what you might put down
or have put down on your to feel list
one of the things that shows up
often on my
to feel list is some
version of breathing
which might sound strange but
i you know especially
around this book launch and after the
year we've all had
i'll catch myself in these moments of
busyness
where i realize i'm not taking
real breaths i'm almost holding my
breath and
so that's one thing that's usually at
the top of my list and i do a breathing
meditation every day
so in some senses it kind of correlates
to the actual breathing meditation that
might be on my
to-do list um but yeah breathing
very simple very crucial
and so are these physical sensations
are they emotions does it
sort of run the gamut or you might have
for instance would gratitude be
a good to feel
item or is that not have you just over
time found that
something like that maybe isn't specific
enough or
or otherwise yeah gratitude is often on
that list
i mean i think the idea of that you feel
less is
to kind of just jot down
bullet points and and often while what
i'll do even in my journaling is expand
on say gratitude with more specificity
but they're more kind of like my
my north stars for the day are there
particular prompts
are there any prompts or questions that
you like to use
or that you use have used more than once
i have been doing a journaling prompt
for the last couple of months called
a day in the life of my dream the idea
initially came from my friend holly
jacobs
and you write a day in the life of your
dream
a couple years out and you write it in
the present tense with great specificity
from the moment you wake up until you go
to sleep
and the reason i love this prompt is
because
like i was saying earlier one of
the strange remnants of being sick
is being afraid to make plans for the
future
i'm very comfortable being pinned to the
present
but i still think
in you know hundred day increments and
maybe six month
increments but when i go any further
beyond that i start to feel that sense
of
fear of well what if you know something
thwarts the plan between now and then
what if i get sick
what if what if what if and so that act
of writing
a future dream in the present tense has
really kind of helped assuage that fear
and strangely
some of the things that i've written in
those entries
have happened and again i don't want to
get too
we're not talking about manifesting here
but i do think there's power
in putting something to paper
and like we've been talking about asking
and stating what you want and really
clarifying
what that is for yourself i totally
agree i think the the term manifesting
can take us in all sorts of directions
that we wouldn't want to go but
there's a difference between making
a specific ask or
taking something that is vague and
making it specific
and a vague wish or just hand wavy
magical thinking right there's a
difference and i think
crucially when you
take something that is like a vague
discomfort
or longing and translate it to something
very specific on paper
your selective attention begins to see
things that could contribute to whatever
it is you just wrote down much like if
you buy a new car and then
in the next week you start to see that
new car everywhere
it's not because everyone bought the
same car it's because
your attention is now trained on
something very specific
i think there's tremendous value in that
absolutely and i'll just say
you know i have tried on some dreams for
fit in the last couple of months where
i've written
a day in the life of a particular dream
and come to the conclusion that that is
not in fact my dream
so it's helpful in a number of ways i
find
so you know i have been experimenting
with fiction recently i haven't shared
any of it
little short stories very self-conscious
about
this writing and you know i wanted to
write funny stuff
and both of the stories or at least one
of them
for especially the first one was really
dark and
my girlfriend who actually introduced me
to
the isolation journal also so i want to
give her due credit
was really pissed because i shared my
first story with a
friend before i shared it with her and i
explained that i was embarrassed
that it was so dark and
kind of ashamed that it was so dark
because isn't this supposed to be this
light thing that i'm doing to reorient
towards fun and writing and like this is
really
very dark and i was
doing research for this conversation
this is going somewhere don't worry
and it got into
a description of you i believe was you
interviewing cheryl strait
the author cheryl strait after you
emerged from treatment
and you told her that you wanted to
write a book but not about cancer
in fact you know anything other than
cancer
and she said to you in effect
that you should write the story that you
need to write and that you had no
business
trying to avoid it and that
really uh has stuck in my mind
and i'm wondering if you have anything
further
to add to that or if you want to expand
on it because i can imagine
that after years of feeling all the
feels and having
so many people ask you about your story
i can identify and in my case
with having suffered depression for most
of my life i mean two extended episodes
a year let's just say on average the
last thing i want to do is then take
that and put it into my fiction
could you perhaps just reflect on that
or expand on it
so often writing teachers will tell you
to write
what you know but i often find that i
write what i
want to understand and so
at that time that i had that
conversation with cheryl
i was very much stuck in that in between
place and feeling like
i needed to be out of that in between
place at all costs
but it wasn't until i had that
conversation with her
that i began to ask myself
why am i in this in between place are
other people in this in between place
two what is
there to be learned here what is there
to be observed
and so when i did eventually end up
writing the book i kept a post-it note
above my desk
that said if you want to write a good
book
write what you don't want others to know
about you
if you want to write a great book right
but you don't want to know about
yourself
and to me that has been my kind of
mantra and any kind of writing i do
whether it's
reported features or fiction or my own
stories
but really writing towards that thing
that you either don't want to know
or that you don't understand and want to
know better
that's hardcore i like it it's very
that's
that's i think you know part of the
reason why i'm like oh god
she's like getting into lamaze breathing
is because it
rings of truth did you come up with that
is that your
expression or your mantra it is
something that a friend
told me benjamin shoyer but i don't
think it was his own
mantra i think it's one that's been
passed down
to desperate artists and writers who are
trying to get
unstuck so i can't take credit for it
well suleika i think you know we've
covered
a lot i think we may just need to do
around two
at some point but i'd love to ask a few
more questions
and then certainly open the floor i'm
not in any rush
to anything else you might want to
discuss but
let me ask a question that is often a
terrible question
and yep yes so sometimes it works
sometimes it doesn't but
i'm curious if you could put
a message a quote an image anything at
all non-commercial
on a billboard metaphorically speaking
right that would
get the
content of that billboard out to
millions or billions of people
assuming they all understand whatever
language is being used
what might you put on that billboard
could be something of your own could be
something from someone else
anything at all does anything come to
mind i
would put the epigraph in my book
which is a line from miguel cervantes
that says until death it is all life
that's fantastic that is fantastic and i
would put it at the top of the
holland tunnel for all the busy
commuters
stressing and and frantically driving to
work
hopefully not the wrong way down yeah
hopefully not the wrong way
not directly into traffic um slick is
there anything else that you would like
to mention anything you'd like
to point people to any requests you
would like to make
of my audience before we
come to a close for this first
conversation i guess the only thing i
haven't really
talked about is the isolation journals
um let's talk about it
let's let's let's talk about it some
more because i think it's
it has been a lifeline for so many and
it is a way to
as i think you've put it reconnect to
joy and curiosity
that has attracted 100 000 plus people
so i think it's worth spending at least
a few minutes on so would you like to
take the mic and and go from there so at
the beginning
of the pandemic i was struck by how
familiar
it all felt that experience of
navigating the world
with a mask of walking around with
gallons of
hand sanitizer that sense of hyper
vigilance all of it was so similar
to what i'd experienced when i was sick
except that of course we were all living
it together on a global scale
so i had the idea of returning to that
100 day project
that i done with my friends and family
except this time i wanted to open it up
to a bigger community and i wanted to
invite people to journal alongside
with me and so i reached out
to some friends different artists and
writers and musicians i reached out to a
couple
of my heroes and idols and ask them if
they might
be willing to contribute a journaling
prompt
and so that's what we've done every week
for the last year we've put out
a new journaling prompt that's free and
that's accessible to everyone whether
you're an artist or
a lifelong journaler or you're very
skeptical about the idea
of writing in a notebook and are curious
to check it out
but i think you know the biggest thing
that struck me is the
sense of community that's formed
around the project and more specifically
around these journal entries that that
some people are
are willing to share and it's just
been an affirmation for me
of the fact that that survival
is really its own kind of creative act
um and that when we
dare to be vulnerable we learn again and
again
that we're more alike than we are
different
here here where is the best place
for people to go if they want to
learn more about or somehow participate
in the isolation journal to see these
prompts
experience them to experiment with all
these things
so we send the prompts out via
newsletter
and um you can sign up for the
newsletter at theisolationjournals.com
isolationjournals.com also if people are
feeling adventurous with their spelling
trust me you'll find it because
google will identify every misspelling
suleika
joad that's a j s-u-l-e-i-k-a-j-a o
u a d dot com we will link to all social
it's at salika jawad on twitter and
instagram
we'll link to facebook and everything
else in the show notes at tim.log
slash podcast if you want to also find a
link to the isolation journals you can
see
one of the prompts that jumped out at me
because it was shared with me by my
girlfriend
at tim.log dialogue
and suleika what a great
pleasure it has been to spend time with
you thank you so much
thank you tim i've loved it hey guys
this is tim again just a few more things
before you take off
number one this is five bullet friday
do you want to get a short email from me
would you enjoy getting a short email
from me every friday
that provides a little more soul of fun
before the weekend and five bullet
friday is a very short email
where i share the coolest things i've
found or that i've been pondering over
the week
that could include favorite new albums
that i've discovered it could include
gizmos and gadgets and all sorts of
weird that i've somehow dug up
in the uh the world of the esoteric as i
do it could include
favorite articles that i've read and
that i've shared with
my close friends for instance and it's
very short it's just
a little tiny bite of goodness before
you head off
for the weekend so if you want to
receive that check it out
just go to four hourworkweek.com that's
four hourworkweek.com all spelled out
and just drop in
your email and you will get the very
next one and if you sign up
i hope you enjoy it this episode is
brought to you by all form
if you've been listening to this podcast
for a while you've probably heard me
talk about helix
sleep and their mattresses which i've
been using since 2017. i have two of
them
upstairs from where i'm sitting at this
moment and now helix has gone beyond the
bedroom and started making
sofas they just launched a new company
called all form a-l-l-f-o-r-m and
they're making premium
customizable sofas and chairs shipped
right to your door at a fraction of the
cost of traditional stores
so i'm sitting in my living room right
now and it's entirely all form
furniture i've got two chairs i've got
an ottoman and i have an
l sectional couch and i'll come back to
that
you can pick your fabric they're all
spill stained and scratch resistant the
sofa color
the color of the legs the surface size
the shape to make sure it's perfect for
you and your home
also all form arrives in just three to
seven days and you can assemble it all
yourself in a few minutes no tools
needed i was quite astonished by how
modular
and easy these things fit together kind
of like lego pieces they've got arm
chairs love seats all the way up to an
8c
sectional so there's something for
everyone you can also start small and
kind of build on top of it if you want
to get a smaller couch and then build
out on it which is actually in a way
what i did because i can turn
my l-sectional couch into a normal
straight couch and then with a separate
ottoman
in a matter of about 60 seconds it's
pretty rad so
i mentioned i have all these different
things in this room i use the natural
leg finish which is their lightest color
and i dig it and i've been using these
things hours and hours and hours
every single day so i am using
what i am sharing with you guys and if
getting a sofa without trying it in
store sounds risky
you don't need to worry all form sofas
are delivered directly to your home with
fast free shipping and you get 100 days
to decide if you want to keep it
that's more than three months and if you
don't love it they'll pick it up for
free and give you a full refund
your sofa frame also has a forever
warranty that's literally
forever so check it out take a look
they've got all sorts of cool stuff
to choose from i was skeptical and it
actually worked it worked much better
than i could have
imagined and i'm very very happy so to
find your perfect sofa check out
allform.com
tim that's a-l-l-f-o-r-m.com
tim all form is offering 20 off all
orders to you my dear listeners at
allform.com
tim make sure to use the code tim at
checkout
that's allforum.com tim and use code tim
at checkout this episode is brought to
you by element
spelled lmnt what on earth is element
it is a delicious sugar-free electrolyte
drink mix
i've stocked up on boxes and boxes of
this it was one of the first things that
i bought
when i saw covid coming down the pike
and i usually use
one to two per day element is formulated
to help anyone with their electrolyte
needs and perfectly suited to folks
following a keto low carb
or paleo diet or if you drink a ton of
water and you might not
have the right balance that's often when
i drink it or if you're doing any type
of endurance exercise
mountain biking etc another application
if you've ever struggled to feel good
on keto low carb or paleo it's most
likely because
even if you're consciously consuming
electrolytes you're just not getting
enough
and it relates to a bunch of stuff like
a hormone called aldosterone
blah blah blah when insulin is low but
suffice to say this is where element
again spelled lmnt can help my favorite
flavor by far
is citrus salt which is a side note you
can also use to make a kick ass
no sugar margarita but for special
occasions obviously
you're probably already familiar with
one of the names behind it
rob wolf r-o-b-b rob wolf who is a
former research biochemist and
two-time new york times best-selling
author of the paleo solution and wired
to eat
rob created element by scratching his
own itch
that's how it got started his brazilian
jiu jitsu coaches turned him onto
electrolytes
as a performance enhancer things clicked
and bam
company was born so if you're on a low
carb diet or
fasting electrolytes play a key role in
relieving hunger cramps headaches
tiredness
and dizziness sugar artificial
ingredients coloring
all that's garbage unneeded there's none
of that in element
and a lot of names you might recognize
are already using element it was
recommended to be
by one of my favorite athlete friends
three navy seal teams as prescribed by
their master chief marine units fbi
sniper teams at least
five nfl teams who have subscriptions
they are the exclusive hydration partner
to team usa weightlifting and on and on
you can try it risk free if you don't
like it element will give you your money
back no questions as
they have extremely low return rates
element came up with a very special
offer for you my dear listeners for a
limited time you can claim a free
element sample pack you only cover the
cost of shipping
for u.s customers this means you can
receive an eight-count sample pack
for just five dollars simply go to drink
elements.com
tim that's drink lmnt.com tim
to claim your free 8 count sample pack
one more time that's drink
l mnt tim for this exclusive offer
drinkelements.com tim check it out
you